i got a um a lovely letter from an
executive at abc who said howard we
heard you yesterday
uh please come on celebrity family feud
you can have your radio family play the
wack pack anything you want we want you
on celebrity family feud yes
but uh i know i would [ __ ] up and steve
harvey would give that face to the
camera that
he does and it's so great because you go
yep steve's letting us know
this guy's an idiot oh look who it is
high pitched powers how
are you if i do celebrity family feud
would you come on
oh yes absolutely oh you're available
you know john hein has a couple of
family feud type questions let me just
ask me one and i'll show you how i'll
[ __ ] it up i'll choke okay we surveyed
100 people
the uh top eight answers are on the
board here's the question
you would like steve harvey a little
more energy name something
associated with vampires
fighting biting
are you kidding me biting isn't biting
in blood
well blood is but biting isn't what are
you saying eric
i said teeth teeth is not a correct
answer
fangs is a correct answer
if he said teeth bangs would have been
accepted let me try a different one
name something in a person's closet that
only comes
out on special occasions evening games
evening gown uh dress is the number two
response i said suits suit or
tux is the number one answer okay
there's my point
i'm not going on i'm not gonna go on
national tv
and lose to this [ __ ] guy and that's
my problem
that's my no offense eric howard i have
two more that i think you're gonna get
your confidence up eric get ready here
we go
but to just understand something okay as
you're listening to eric just beat me
okay you you're missing the whole point
of this yeah broken clock is right twice
a day
i'm telling you i [ __ ] i i get nervous
and when i play with my wife at home i'm
a genius i do it great
gown was a good answer
eric head number one eric not somebody
else
eric nothing can change my mind now that
eric beat me all right eric you ready
here we go when you enter a bathroom
what color do you really hope not to see
in the toilet bowl brown powder brown
number one and
[Music]
but that's what i mean eric beat me on
an answer and he just answered the same
answer
this one is more up your alley eric so
howard if you beat eric on this one you
should feel good about yourself
go ahead name something you find
in a breakfast buffet eggs pancakes
pancakes is not on the list eggs
is the number one answer
[Music]
and then what happens is then you go
okay we'll take it steve
now what was the category again john
name something you find at a breakfast
buffet
now you gotta go like bacon number two
sausage sauce number three
okay and then you start browns number
four answer
you see here's the problem she thought
of hashbrowns steve will come to me and
i'll go um uh
um uh you know what i mean i was already
out of juice
juice number five answer welcome
if you had said steve i'm out of juice
you would have gotten through
is flies on there
[Laughter]
life is not it's not cereal
cereal is the number eight answer yes
how many more do we have
two more there are two more answers no
no here don't say don't say anything
coffee is the number six answer you're
very good now at this point
now it's howard's turn now it's my turn
and it'd be like
um met him useful crackers
show us metamucil crackers stop it
howard you've got it
yogurt e coli
the remaining answer is melon melon is
the last one i'm gonna say fruit would
you have accepted that
robin is that person i'm feud who always
goes afterwards i was gonna save fruit
no
no no no i was gonna say fruit but then
i said
cereal because cereal has to be there
yeah
well you should have said fruit uh well
fruit and serious
i was gonna say that you can't do that
i'm telling you i'm feud
look you know what i was gonna say i was
gonna say mouse [ __ ] because that most
of these places particularly manhattan
who knows what he's doing